>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Our author this afternoon
is James McGrath Morris
and I for one am very
excited to hear from him.
As you may know, the news business
is undergoing some soul searching
and some financial distress, and so
it's gratifying to talk to someone
who has had so much success
writing about journalism
and about the news business
and the very interesting
characters that have built it.
His books include The Rose Man of
Sing Sing: A True Tale of Life,
Murder, and Redemption in the
Age of Yellow Journalism as well
as Jailhouse Journalism: The
Fourth Estate Behind Bars.
The book he'll be discussing today
is his most recent work Pulitzer:
A Life in Politics,
Print, and Power.
It is my great pleasure to
give you James McGrath Morris.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you very much.
About six months ago, I was
doing what authors usually do
which is travel to small towns
because there are people
who buy and read books.
And I was in a bookstore where a
really kind reader felt my pain
and asked me a softball question.
So he said to me, "You spent five
years studying this guy's life.
Is there any kind of practical
thing that you learned from it?"
I thought, had mumbled some
sort of incoherent answer.
Well, six months later
I have the answer.
So if he's out there,
here's the answer.
And if you wanna take
notes, feel free.
The answer is if you make a lot of
money in life and you endow a prize
like Pulitzer did,
everybody will know the prize,
but they will not remember
who the heck you were.
And for me as an author, this
actually gave me an opportunity
because there are a lot of giants
in the 19th century, Morgan,
Rockefeller, and we think
they have no connection
to our lives, but they do.
Most of you drove an oil-powered
automobile to come here.
We're talking about Rockefeller.
Many of you are hopefully
gonna run over and buy a book,
and you're gonna whip out a
credit card which is based
on a financial system
invented by Morgan.
Well, Pulitzer is one of those
geniuses from the 19th century
who is the midwife of the modern
mass media who, in a sense,
may have brought you here.
You learned about the
event maybe electronically
on the Washington Post
website but this whole notion
of disseminating news and all
of those things are owed to us
or came to us from Pulitzer.
And so for me as an author,
it's a great opportunity
because here I'm writing about one
of the giants of the 19th century
who most people knew nothing about.
So unlike reading about
Morgan or Rockefeller,
everytime you turn the page
it's an opportunity for me
to tell you something new.
So I wanna leave you with a couple
of aspects of why Pulitzer is
so important to us, how, in a
sense, his hand is still reaching
out through the grave and
touching our lives today
and affecting the way
we communicate,
the way we organize news.
And I'm not gonna tell
you an old story
about Pulitzer who'd start off
life as a Hungarian immigrant,
came here as a mercenary soldier.
I wanna tell you about how
he reshaped journalism which,
in a sense, was a boring
craft before the man arrived
and changed things.
And the first seminal
moment is in 1878
when he invests his last few dollars
in buying a bankrupt evening paper
in the City of Saint Louis on the
steps of the Saint Louis courthouse,
the same courthouse that
decided the Dred Scott decision.
And all his friends think he's
nuts, an afternoon paper in a city
where three afternoon
papers are being published,
none of which are making money
and he's buying a bankrupt paper.
And this is one of the
distinguishing moments in his life
that will reflect the
characteristics that caused him
to reshape our society
because he's not an inventor.
He's not like Bell or somebody
who said, "Gee, we need a gadget
where we can talk to each other."
What he was is a man who could
perceive huge social trends,
sort of like the Tuckfield
[phonetic] did before.
And the analogy I give and people
think I've really lost my marbles
when I suddenly asked you to imagine
a surfer, and here I'm talking
about a 19th century figure.
But I want you to see this
before I talk about Pulitzer.
If you've ever been to the coast
where there are surfers and you look
out on the waves, far past the
waves where they're breaking,
they'll be young men and
women on their boards
and they're probably
old surfers, too.
Let's just say, men and
women on their boards.
And they're paddling very slowly
and suddenly they paddle furiously
and they ride a huge
wave that forms.
Somehow, those good surfers are able
to detect the slight undulations
in the water and realize
that's the big wave.
Pulitzer did that with our society.
Here he was in Saint
Louis and he realized
that farmers were leaving their
farms in Illinois and Missouri
and coming to the city
because of industrialization.
They were becoming factory workers.
So what were they doing?
They were commuting.
Women who used to be important
economic decision makers
on the farms were now
becoming housewives.
It's all gonna play into something
you're gonna see in a second.
Gaslight and electric light allowed
people to entertain themselves
in the evening by reading.
A new printing press
had been invented by Hoe
that could print papers quickly.
Paper was being made from trees
that had the tensile strength to go
through these machines at high speed
and the Victorian Internet
had arrived.
You call it the telegraph bringing
news from New York and Washington
to Saint Louis as fresh
as that morning.
So he took all of these ingredients
and published an afternoon paper
with news from Washington and New
York as fresh as that morning,
sold it to commuters heading home
desperate for entertainment filled
with entertaining tales
about the city
and economic decision making
material for the housewives,
advertisements, where can you buy
gingham, where can you buy flower.
And as a result, he created this
new medium of mass communication
in Saint Louis that
became a huge success.
So now, let's move along
and see why it went
from Saint Louis to elsewhere.
New York in the 19th century
was really the capital
of the United States.
Now, I know you're thinking
here I have come to Washington
and I'm saying I'm ignorant.
No, no, no.
This was a swamp infested place
that only politicians went.
Broadway and the music and the
theater, that was New York.
Publishing, that was New York.
Media, the newspapers,
that was New York.
And so Pulitzer was waiting
and biding his time to get
to New York and he did the same.
He came to New York in 1883,
bought a bankrupt newspaper,
brought his western style
of journalism to New York
and became an instant success
there with a newspaper none
of us know anymore because
it's gone, the New York World.
And it was such a success instantly
because he replicated what
he learned in Saint Louis,
but he added something
very important.
As an immigrant, he looked to
the lower East Side of New York
and saw these vast teeming
waves of new Americans
and he didn't see them as a threat.
He saw them as a strength, as
something he could like himself,
they're gonna contribute
to the United States.
So he admonished his reporters to
go and write about their lives.
So his reporters descended on the
lower East Side and wrote stories
about their lives, but not
just about their lives.
They were using Dickens
as their model,
tell stories about their lives.
So the world would come out
with a headline, "Tiny tot falls
to its death as mother looks on."
And on the upper reaches of Fifth
Avenue where people drink their tea
with their little finger up, one
of them said, "Hey, Elizabeth,
look at this sensationalistic
prattle that's going
on in the paper."
And they were missing the
point because if you went
to the lower East Side and you
went in the Black and Tan bars
or the overcrowded dining
rooms of those tenement houses,
what were those families
talking about?
They were indeed talking
about the children
that had fallen off the
roof the night before
because the tenements were so
hot, something we know today
in this tent, so hot
that in order to sleep,
people went to the top
floor and children sometimes
at night rolled off the
roofs to their deaths.
So he wasn't covering
sensationalism.
He was writing about their lives.
And as a result, he gave
them a newfound dignity.
Now, if any of you
were to invite me home,
and don't worry this is just an
analogy, you don't have to do this,
I'm betting that on your
refrigerators you have a clipping,
a clipping of a wedding, your son
and daughter's school
achievements, sports things.
Those events occurred
irregardless of the clipping.
The clipping, the putting it to
print gives that moment a dignity,
a meaningful representation
that you cherish and keep.
Well, imagine in the world
before television and radio,
those stories encapsulated
their lives
and gave dignity to those people.
And for once, somebody was
paying attention to them.
So they in return would spend their
pennies buying the paper, of course,
making the New York World this
enormous success reaching a
circulation of a million copies
when they're only 64 million
people in the United States.
>> So as this goes on,
there's something else
that relates to their lives.
The French have decided to give
us a gift, the Statue of Liberty.
And if you remember your history,
the Statue of Liberty is a gift
of the French people
to the American people,
not of the French government.
The French people had
raised the money privately
and in turn we were supposed
to raise the money,
but we were failing.
So Pulitzer put it on the front
page of his newspaper that the money
to build the pedestal for
the statue is not coming in.
He editorialized and said, "We
need to bring this money in."
And people everyday, poor
people, kids, came to the paper
and gave a penny or a nickel.
Now, it may not seem
like much but understand.
Pulitzer is like a
rubber baron of that time.
He's a corporate chieftain.
And the poorest people on New York
were coming in and entrusting them
with their pennies and nickels
for the Statue of Liberty.
And in return, he was putting
their name in the newspaper.
So a kid, what they called
street Arabs or street urchins,
by giving the world a penny would
have his name in the same newspaper
that covered the Astors,
the Vanderbilts,
and all the great names in society.
So the pedestal was
built with that money.
The statue arrived
and it was erected
with the money of these people.
So Pulitzer was changing the New
York landscape by his new use
of media and exemplifying
a kind of intimate trust
that no institution
might have today.
I don't think many of you are gonna
rush to some large corporation
and give them some
change and say I trust you
to keep it for some project.
We have foundations in 501c3's.
So there's another
change that's gonna go
on that's gonna symbolize how he's
changed our lives and created--
or was the midwife of
the modern mass media.
His papers become such a success
it needs a new headquarters
and Pulitzer's life is
becoming a dramatic change
because he's falling blind.
So like Beethoven who
can't hear his own music,
Pulitzer can't read his own work,
but he's creating this
huge media enterprise
and it needs a new headquarters.
So he chooses a spot in New York
and this is the second
practical lesson for you.
He buys a hotel called
French's Hotel.
French's Hotel was a hotel on
Park Row that had thrown them
out of the lobby when he
was unemployed veteran.
And if you remember the old adage,
"Revenge is a dish
best served cold."
Twenty years later, he
comes back, buys the hotel,
and tears it down for
his headquarters.
Now, Park Row is significant in
another way in that time period.
This is the world before
Twitter, before CNN,
before any of these
kinds of communications.
So if you wanted to know
who won the election,
you would go down to Park
Row and on the buildings,
they would have blackboards and
they would write Cleveland is ahead.
Well, it wasn't just elections.
Everybody went to Park Row.
When America's cup was waged,
they telegraphed the results
and they had small
ships that moved across.
There was a boxing match
on one of the islands
and they have marionettes reenacting
the fight as the telegraphs came in.
Now, for those of you who are old
enough, you're gonna get this.
Think about it.
The crowd loved it so much
they asked the marionette crew
to do it all over again.
That is instant replay a century
before ABC's Wide World of Sports.
So Park Row is a terrifically
important aspect
of life in New York.
It's the Fleet Street.
It's where the Tribune was, a little
unknown newspaper called the New
York Times, the Herald, and the New
York World was being built there.
So he built the tallest
building on the globe.
And on the top of it was
a dome that was gold leaf.
And in that office was where the
editorial crew that wrote the World
and produced the paper that
on Sundays was as thick
as a telephone book with
things like dress patterns.
The greatest invention of that time,
of course, the Color Sunday Comic
or cartoon, sheet music
that you could use
to play long before we had
iPods and could download music.
You could buy the New York
World and get sheet music
and play the newest song that
night in your home, recipes,
serialization of novels,
economic instruction.
So this immigrant population turned
to the World for all of this kind
of instruction on Sundays and
got it for just a few pennies.
So this building went up and it was
the tallest building in the world
at that point on the globe, and it
was at the centerpiece of New York.
So just like he was redoing the
American mass media and reshaping,
and he was reshaping the New York
skyline in a way that's so symbolic
that I wanna finish
telling you this tale.
Imagine these immigrants now
coming to the United States
in the late 19th century,
1890 or so.
And folks, this isn't a casual trip.
They are leaving Ukraine,
Poland, and places like that.
When they say goodbye
to their parents,
there's no cheap Delta
flight home next year
to come home for the holidays.
They probably never
see their family alive.
They're gambling their last pennies
to come to this new land and try
to get a foothold in
this economic dream.
So they're arriving in the
New York harbor and steerage
in these overcrowded ships,
and they come up to the deck
and the first thing they're gonna
see is the Statue of Liberty
on a pedestal erected by
the pennies and nickels
of the people who came before them.
Now, they may be ignorant
of the pedestal,
but they knew what the
Statue of Liberty is.
At that moment, they turned and
they looked at the New York skyline
for the first time in their
lives and it's their first view
of the world in which they are
basing their future hopes on.
And if the conditions
are just right,
the sun is gleaming
off the gold dome.
And so the tallest building,
taller than Trinity Church,
the thing that's lighting up in
the distance is not a monument
to comers, not a monument to
banking or retail or agriculture.
It's a monument to the
American mass media,
the only constitutionally
protected business in our society
and specifically, it's their first
glimpse of the World newspaper
that will be their key
to economic growth,
their key to learning
Americanisms of all sorts,
the English language.
He admonished, Pulitzer
admonished his reporters
to write short punchy sentences
to tell everything in the form
of a story because he knew who
his readers were and, of course,
his interest was political power.
So he hoped they would eventually
turn to the editorial page
and learn his suggestions as who to
vote for, and that certainly worked.
The first Democratic
president elected
after the civil war was Grover
Cleveland and you can do the math.
It's the paper that got him elected.
So what Pulitzer left us with after
changing the New York landscape
physically and changing the American
mass media is a legacy we still have
today, the notion of news
at its core being a story.
He would tell his reporters that
everyday I want people at dinner
to say, "Did you read
that in the World today?"
Producers at NBC or anything are
often saying, "I want my audience
to say, 'Did you see that
story today?'" And the key
to that is the story and the
humanization of the story.
Think of all the great
tragedies that have occurred
in our modern lives, the Haiti
earthquake, famine in Africa.
When you read that millions of
people are hurt by something,
it becomes a number, but we're
moved to act when we read the story
of the one child who's rescued
under the rubble after three days,
and that's the magic that
he was leaving us with,
that in our lives exist
essentially a story and the magic
of the news media is
to capture that story
to humanize it and to give it to us.
And that's why the World grew to
be the most powerful newspaper
in America where governors
in the state
of Oregon would write
all the way to New York
and say, "Would you endorse me?"
And I bet you today that no
governor of Oregon is writing
to the New York Times and
saying, "Would you endorse me?"
And so what I enjoyed about
my five-year journey is it was
like being an archaeologist.
I was uncovering a
world we've forgotten.
The World paper is gone.
We now have other papers
that have replaced it.
Pulitzer is remembered as a trivial
pursuit like a name of a prize,
but no one can tell you what he
did and that was the joy I had
in the last five years writing,
and that's the joy I've had
in answering questions from readers.
Now, I have some time.
I timed it just right, right,
10 minutes to answer questions
and there are mics on each side.
And I'll try not to
take six months to come
up with the appropriate answer.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you very much.
>> What was Pulitzer's
connection to drama, theater,
and the other prizes
that have his name?
>> What was the connection
of Pulitzer to drama,
theater, and other things?
Personal. Pulitzer-- there are a lot
of reasons why the Pulitzer Prize
was created, one of which is
that as you probably know in 1898,
he engages in the circulation
of William Randolph Hearst, yellow
journalism, a pejorative term comes
about and he feels stained by that.
All of his major achievements
are forever linked
to this awful period much
like certain presidents
who might have been in office
for eight years always remembered
for one little moment and
then we forget the rest.
So Pulitzer created the
Pulitzer Prize in part
to cleanse his reputation
and secondly, which I'll get
to in a second about his belief
in journalism that changed.
But the reason there were
prizes for drama, and history,
and music is a personal reflection
of his love of those things.
When he falls blind, he has
readers who travel with him
who read him novels,
he loved Dickens,
who hit a personal
pianist to play music.
He loved opera and he thought
these were important parts
of a civilized society
to have and a reward.
But back to the major prize,
Pulitzer got into journalism
because he wanted political power
and journalism was the other
side of that coin back.
Politics and journalism
were just two sides
of the same coin in
the 19th century.
But as he became a publisher
and worked in journalism,
he came to understand that it
was a far more important craft
than personal political power.
And the most important prize
as far as he was concerned
and it may sound quaint today is the
Pulitzer Prize for Public Service,
the notion that journalism
may be a business.
Yes, you gotta pay your
employees, but at the heart
of it is it's an important part
of American democratic process
and that's part of the
reason for the prize.
Should I-- I guess I should
take turns and go this side.
Yes?
>> You kind of responded
to my question just then,
but maybe you can expand on it.
There's a lot bemoaning now
about the corporate media
and with the implication being
that the pre-corporate media
was somehow very altruistic
and just concerned
about public service.
But it's always been
a business, hasn't it?
And can you talk about
the difference
between the corporate media today
and the corporate media
in the 19th century?
>> Certainly.
They both have-- this is a
question about the corporate media
in the 19th century versus today.
They both have the same
concern and they have
to make money in order to work.
Most of the corporate media, I
think, in my commentary that engages
in a greater public service
are the family-owned newspapers
because those publishers
can make the decision not--
that the stockholders
aren't gonna like.
I'm gonna subsidize the paper
while it's losing money.
And Pulitzer did that at times.
When the paper was losing money,
he would simply subsidize
the enterprise.
But the problem, the corporate
media, family owned or not owned,
and something we all face,
is that news is a terrifically
expensive enterprise
to take an educated soul,
send them to Afghanistan,
and give us important information
about the war is not
a cheap process.
And now that the news media is
finding a struggle to monetize
to get that income is not a
problem for the Washington Post.
Yes, it isn't making money.
It's a problem for us because
our society without that kind
of untethered reporting will
suffer and will become--
will have less and less counter
reviews as to what's going on.
So the problem is they're
similar, but the diversity
in the 19th century was so
much larger than it is today.
Sir?
>> Excuse me.
You mentioned in passing
William Randolph Hearst.
>> Yes.
>> And it seems to be to the extent
to which Pulitzer is
remembered historically,
he tends to be paired with Hearst.
>> Correct.
Yeah.
>> Could you perhaps spend a couple
of minutes doing a little compare
and contrast between the two men?
>> Question is about
the ying and yang.
William Randolph Hearst was
and I'm not belittling Hearst,
but he was ultimately the
best imitator of Pulitzer.
He studied Pulitzer's methods.
He came to New York.
He bought a newspaper that
was interestingly started
by Pulitzer's younger brother
so everyday when Pulitzer opened
up the Journal and realized
this competitor might put him
out of business he was competing
with the work of his brother,
talk about sibling rivalry.
Hearst, in many ways,
outdid Pulitzer on some
of the less good aspects
of their journalism,
engaged in greater
sensationalism than the World did
and was far more successful at that.
But the key moment comes with
the Spanish-American War.
I'm sure many of you heard Mr.
Thomas talking about his book today.
During the Spanish-American War,
these two papers competed in a way
that we've never had
that kind of competition
and they began to make up stories.
Now, Pulitzer was blind and
in depression over the loss
of his daughter in Jekyll Island.
So in New York, William Randolph
Hearst was leading his troops
to compete against the
World and Pulitzer was a--
had troops that had no general.
And they knew if the
paper collapsed,
they couldn't go to work for Hearst.
So every outlandish thing Hearst
did, they tried to do equally so.
To give you an example, Hearst
paper had a story about a colonel
that was killed in the war
with a really odd last name
like Philippe [inaudible]
or something like that.
The World picked up the story
and reprinted it entirely.
The next day, the Journal announced
that if you look at guy's last name,
it's an anagram for
"We pilfer the news."
Now, when the Spanish-American
War was over
and this competition was over,
Pulitzer came back to his senses
and he put out an edict that
they couldn't engage in this kind
of reprehensible sensationalistic
journalism
but the damage had been done.
So I like to give the comparison
to Sherlock Holmes and Moriarty
and I hope you all
read the last story
because if not I'm
giving something away.
They fight in Switzerland and
they both fall to their death.
History will always link.
Open up any high school
history textbook.
There's always Hearst and Pulitzer,
yellow journalist linked in this
and Pulitzer was never
able to escape that.
So all achievements I'm
telling you about are lost
because Pulitzer will
always be linked
as a yellow sensationalistic
journalist.
Thank you.
I'm sorry.
Yes, sir.
>> A few years ago when I was in
the 5th grade, I wrote a paper
on Pulitzer in the Saint Louis Post.
>> I wish I'd found
it during my research.
>> Well, I have talked to
you at politic controls.
We both used the same
little pamphlet
on the history of the Post-Dispatch.
Your book was better and
certainly more recent,
but could you dwell
a little bit more
on the relationship
with his brother?
Was his brother at all successful
and do they dislike each other
or just ignore each other?
>> The question is about
Pulitzer's unknown brother Albert.
Pulitzer came from a large family
in which all the children died
by the time he was 13 except for
his younger brother Albert who came
to the United States after
Joseph Pulitzer and just
like his older brother,
he got into journalism
and this really infuriated
Joseph who was quite an egomaniac
that his younger brother
not only got in journalism
but was doing better than he was.
He started a newspaper in New
York which was nothing but gossip.
It was called the chambermaid's
delight.
I mean that was its nickname.
But it sold copies and here
was his brother, a millionaire,
publishing in New York and
he was stuck in Saint Louis
with a respectable paper,
so it really bugged him.
When he came to New York, he tried
to force his brother to merge papers
which of course is habit
and his brother said,
"Why should I merge with you?"
Pulitzer stole his entire staff.
It didn't matter.
It continued.
Albert later sold the paper
and it became the paper
that William Randolph Hearst got.
What was great for me
was my little moment
of discovery was I
found Albert's memoirs
with his granddaughter
stored in Paris.
So this book is the first to be able
to offer Albert's side of the story
and trust me, it's not exactly
flattering to his older brother.
And any of you who have siblings
would just love this kind of aspect.
I got time for one more
question and I'll answer briefly.
I am watching the clock.
>> Hi. I'm sorry.
I missed--
>> Can you come closer to
the mic so I can hear you?
>> I'm sorry.
I missed most of your
presentation, but I was just curious
with newspapers versus like media
that, you know, is on television.
I don't really understand why
anybody endorses a candidate.
I guess I'd look at the newspaper--
>> Why they endorse a
candidate, you're saying?
>> Right, because I look at
it as an objective field,
but I guess I'm missing something.
>> The question is why endorse a
candidate in an objective field.
This may be an issue of my age.
See, when I grew up, I
learnt how to be media savvy.
The front page of the
newspaper was news.
The owner who owned the editorial
page expressed his or her opinion
as to who would be elected and
these two things don't always agree.
Any of you who've read the Wall
Street Journal wonder if the people
in the editorial page are
reading the front page
because the front page
may talk about, you know,
how some financial bill is
gonna ruin America and you turn
to the editorial page, it
says we gotta pass this bill.
That was much more common today.
I think what's happening
with broadcast is those distinctions
are becoming more blurry.
Certain networks, particularly one
that might start with letter F tends
to engage in what we might as older
people feel like editorialization
in the reporting, and
that's a change.
That's not the way the
media originally was.
There was a cardinal line that
divided the editorial division
from the news division and the
news division often reported stuff
that the owners in the
editorial page didn't like.
But I'll leave you
with this thought.
A leibling said this and this is why
those folks enjoy owning newspapers.
Freedom of the press,
as you remind us,
belongs to those who
own the presses.
And so if you ever get upset about
an editorial in the Washington Times
or the Washington Post, there
is an op-ed section edited
by a wonderful man, get
your voice in there,
and that would have been the
thing Pulitzer would have liked
because he was one
of the first people
to ever publish an op-ed article,
meaning an article by an individual
that appeared on the paper that
might not agree with his viewpoint.
Thank you.
You're a delightful group.
[ Applause ]
>> And thank you on behalf of
all the authors for the kind
of support you give us as writers.
When we're working
alone for five years,
it's nice to know you're out there.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.